Well,
so then Japan,
oh,
shows up and he's a kindly old guy,
which is pretty much exactly what you'd
expect and you know,
he,
he's a careful craftsman and he likes
kittens and you know,
that's always a good thing and he has
some fish and I know he's and he's good
at making things and he's got a sense of
humor and he's kind of playful and so
he's,
he's a,
he's a good father.
Fundamentally.
He's the wise king.
He's the positive archetype of the
masculine.
That's what he is and so he's culture
and it's positive manifestation and he
gives rise to this creation which is his
puppet,
which is what culture does because
you're a puppet of your culture.
You're a Marionette of your culture,
and so maybe you could be more than
that.
And that's the other thing that's
strange about this movie and it's
strange about the mythological way of
looking at the world because
scientifically deterministically,
there's nature and there's culture and
you are the deterministic product of the
interaction between nature and culture.
There's nothing else to you than that.
That's that.
But the mythological world doesn't say
that.
It says something different,
it says that there's nature and culture
and then there's you and the you that's
in there has choices and the destiny and
that you actually affect the interplay
of nature and culture in determining
your own character.
And it insists upon that the oldest
stories we have,
there's always the hero and the
archetypal mother and the archetype
father.
There's always those three things.
There's never just two.
So from the narrative perspective,
there's always the implication that
there is something autonomous about the,
the hero of the story and you know,
you can't account for that.
We don't have a good way of accounting
for that from a scientific perspective.
I was having a discussion with Sam
Harris the other day,
which was very,
um,
what would you say?
He said we got wrapped around an axle,
which is pretty much has.
Sam Harris is one of the four famous,
you know,
atheists along with Christopher Hitchens
and Richard Dawkins and Dan Dennett.
Yeah.
And so we were having a discussion and
um,
he's a determinist just right down to
the bottom.
It's like you're determined,
you're determined.
There's no freewill.
You're a deterministic machine and you
know if you're a coherent scientist and
you're a Newtonian,
roughly speaking,
you don't really have much choice other
than to think that way,
but that isn't how it seems to people
and we don't treat each other that way
and our entire legal system is
predicated on the idea that you do in
fact have freewill,
so well.
Can we account for it?
Well,
no,
and do we have a scientific model for
it?
No,
but then I would also say we do not have
a scientific model for consciousness.
We don't know a damn thing about
consciousness,
which is why Dan Dan book,
which was called consciousness
explained,
was referred to.
It's by it's critics as consciousness
explained a way,
which is exactly right as far as I'm
concerned because he took a mechanistic
and I just don't think you get to do
that because there's something really
weird about consciousness.
I mean the phenomenologists Heidegger,
who tried to radically transform western
philosophy right from the bottom up.
He basically said,
well,
you know,
you can treat the world as if
consciousness is primary and that human
experience is reality.
That's reality and that he doesn't exist
independently of consciousness in any
explicable way.
It's like,
well,
what's out there?
If there's nothing to to experience it
while everything at once.
It's something like that.
It's.
It's not really comprehensible as
without a subject that subject defines
it and makes it real.
Now you don't have to believe that,
but,
but at least I'm telling you that there
are thoroughly coherent philosophical
positions that make that case very
strongly and that that allow
consciousness to exist as a phenomena
and to take it seriously and you
certainly act like you take it
seriously.
You Act like there's a you and that you
make choices and you certainly treat
other people that way.
Deterministic or not,
you're still going to get angry when
they're being rude to you and you're
going to act as if they had some choice
in the matter.
Now,
maybe that's an illusion possibly,
but maybe it's not,
and I would say the oldest stories that
we have always include that as not only
as a fundamental element,
but even as the fundamental element.